Salut Julien, ça va ?
Euh, oui, mais qu'est-ce que tu...
Ah ben justement, je me demandais, t'as déjà remarqué que...
Non mais attends, tu fais quoi là ?
Ben, je tente un truc, un truc nouveau.
Je renouvelle l'émission.
D'accord, mais on en parle avant peut-être, non ?
Mais oui, évidemment !
Voilà !
Tu... Tu me rends ma blouse ?
Tu... TU ME RENDS !
Ça fait maintenant plus d'un an que DTC existe...
Et je me suis dit que c'était le bon moment pour faire un petit bilan avec vous juste avant l'été.
Oui parce que, cet été comme l'année dernière,  on va ralentir la cadence.
Une vidéo toutes les deux semaines au lieu d'une vidéo par semaine, parce que de toute façon tout le monde a beaucoup mieux à faire.
Mais on va quand-même traiter des sujets estivaux, des sujets de vacances pour ceux qui ont la chance d'en avoir,
mais aussi pour les autres.
Alors, venons-en à ce petit bilan.
Cette année on a tenté des nouveaux formats, les "J'ai testé", les "Dans son corps" avec des invités, et même une espèce de vlog sur mes séances de laser.
On va continuer !
Parce que j'aime bien et qu'apparemment vous aussi.
Pour la rentrée, j'ai d'autres idées et d'autres projets mais je me suis  dit que ce serait pas mal que vous me disiez, vous, ce que vous avez envie de voir sur DTC.
Alors évidemment, je promets pas de pouvoir tout faire,
mais s'il y a des idées intéressantes qui sont réalisables, en s'entend,
s'il y a des demandes qui reviennent beaucoup, je vous promets de me pencher très sérieusement sur la question.
Donc n'hésitez pas, donnez-moi vos idées, faites-moi vos demandes dans les commentaires de cette vidéo.
Tant que vous êtes là et tant que je suis là,
j'en profite pour vous dire que je reçoit énormément de messages
de plus en plus de messages, auxquels j'essaye de répondre à tous les coups
mais il y en a beaucoup
j'ai pas mal de trucs à faire donc parfois je traine, je suis désolé.
Vraiment je fais le max, en tous cas vraiment un grand merci
pour votre confiance, ça fait vraiment chaud au coeur.
Dans ces messages certains d'entre vous me demandent des conseils
ou mon avis sur un problème de santé très précis
qui les touchent  personnellement.
J'essaye toujours de répondre mais attention
ayez bien conscience de deux choses :
D'abord, je ne suis pas médecin, je suis infirmier
et ensuite un médecin pour pouvoir vous aider, il a besoin de vous voir
de discuter avec vous, de vous examiner
de connaître vos dossiers, etc.
Et tout ça de toute façon ce n'est pas possible
en échangeant des mails, ou des messages sur Facebook.
Donc allez voir votre médecin.
Vous êtes aussi très nombreux à me demander si vous pouvez venir parler dans DTC
de votre particularité à vous
que ce soit une maladie physique ou mentale, un handicap etc.
Alors ça me touche beaucoup, mais c'est très complexe
pour plein de raisons et notamment parceque vous êtes très nombreux
mais je vous promets, je vais me pencher sur la question
et essayer de réfléchir à une solution.
Pour finir ce bilan, parce que vous avez sûrement pleins de questions à me poser
je vous propose une petite F.A.Q des un an.
Alors là encore, direction les commentaires
posez moi les toutes les questions que vous voulez
sur DTC, sur moi, sur tout ce que vous voulez
et je reviens très bientôt pour y répondre.
Donc on fait le bilan du bilan
dans les commentaires, dites moi ce que vous attendez de DTC pour la saison prochaine
et posez moi vos questions pour la F.A.Q
Voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo
puis pour la F.A.Q, bien sûr.
D'ici là, mettez vous bien et surtout
[Romain] :  portez vous bien !
-Non, vraiment je te jure Romain, avant de tenter des trucs
je préfèrerai qu'on en parle...
-Oui, Bien sûr, bien sûr...